Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Alright, today's Maestro Hook.
A Hook is a good conversation piece you can use when you're talking with a foreigner for a good topic.
Today is about personal questions.
Westerners really like to ask you personal questions and they want to intrude into your life.
For example, your marital status, your age, your job, even maybe your salary.
But it's not rude, this is a cultural thing.
Western people wanna know more about you because they are interested in you.
So, when they ask you this kind of questions, don't be insulted.
You don't have to answer, but there's no harm in answering them.
So, it's just a form of communication, so don't worry about it.
And you can ask the questions too.
Alright.
Private.
Personal.
Personal question.
Can I ask you a personal question?
Personal time.
I need some personal time.
Okay. Personal matter.
That's a personal matter.
Private.
Okay, and...
Out of line.
You are out of line.
I'm sorry, that's out of line.
For example,...
..."Excuse me, can I ask you a personal question?"
"Oh, go ahead!"
"By all means."
"Can I ask you a personal question?"